So, as you know,
there is a slight drought in terms of the,
no golf balls have been
made this year, so.
It's true.
People are having to use smaller fruits.
You're going for a red apple today.
Yeah, slightly unreliable,
but generally a good choice.
And nine iron for...
No, it's a bit of a pitching wedge,
bit of a long wedge, get
a bit of loft on there.
Yeah, 100 yards maybe?
Yeah, that.
All right, go for it.
Think I missed it completely.
Well, you got some good distance on that.
Yes.
I think you're on the fairway,
so let's see if I'm gonna match it.
Reach the green.
Going for a birdie.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Should I be ready on this, yeah?
Ready?
Yeah.
No, go and practice.
Look at your stance.
What?
Go on.
What's wrong with my stance?
Ready?
Yeah.
It hit me in the head.
Hit me in the face.
Yeah, it does that.
Well, it turns out that golf ball drought
I mentioned earlier was actually a lie.
I was just full on lying about that,
so there's a golf ball,
there's a high speed camera,
5,000 frames, let's
see what it looks like.
Let's do it.
Oh sake.
Hit back.
Oh you
I tell you what,
this is pissing me off now.
Aw
Hit it.
That was
That'll do.
Getting pissed off at this.
That'll do, that'll do.
This is the most annoying sport.
I never wanna play golf ever.
Ever wanna play it.